how do we describe
cancel manuel well firstly one
describes him as the helm of a warrior
of life with a lot of desire for self-
improvement then we describe him as a
normal person he does not have any kind of
difficulty we describe him as a
tremendous man he said thank god or all
for  take this route and I didn't do the other
[Music]
[Applause]
more
[Music]
with the squad
[Applause]
as I arrived
a landscape you don't know it can be so you know they
are different in different
wedding cultures custom and everything alarms  From here,
from English
to no one, a secret of all
beginnings are difficult, but those of
us brothers who have not helped us here is
that there are many Latinos living, many of whom are
rich, there are many Dominicans.
it
makes it a little easier for us to
develop I don't understand that it is true
that it is very exciting to see
the support that the United States
has also given it because do  Wherever he goes
to all the states they have welcomed him as
if he belonged detected or
that
we are more than grateful for everything
that is happening and with all the support
that I am a good talent that continues to move
forward and continues to focus on what I
I am that I never gave up keep it up
until good morning I am very Caribbean life of life
wow wow with the beatles
spain thank you very much for the
invitation today we take into account
all personal knowledge that I am my
talent and nothing was a good experience
will be there in  that camp and
treat him, you know,
I have always thought big and beautiful,
I say this because you
know that I have never had an obstacle in my
life, you know,
you can do something, I can also
make him leave, allowing me to remain humble
all the time until God allows it,
yes God  You see that one day I'm
focusing, it's going to go up in smoke
to my head, I'm having an event, it's worth seeing,
because in reality that's not me
every day, no, it surprises us more every day
day he tries to overcome himself is
something
that there would be no word to describe it
I
started when I was 6 years old
but you know it was a process from the
beginning because I lost my balance and
all that I was not used to any of
that
and thank God he gave me  the strength and
wisdom to go forward
after the age of eight nine years he
started with his partnership it's always
having a ball in his hand that I did
n't always carry it in the tournament and he
was always in the middle of the court and that's it
after he turned 10 of 11 years old
and at the same time he told me daddy is being
this wrong he is throwing the ball doing
that in his hand and sometimes I didn't
listen to it validity and how is he
realizing that
in the play with  that the frost gandhiji
play it to black' rivers apps loader las
warmis this is life is the head in the
well-being clan in the management and then to the
axis of the coach and us is from play de
sein there are many memories
because he was my idol yesterday me  it was his
life and h  today he has
become mine that is something that every time
i see him he does things new york and he
plays
the two areas to the natural union thank you
sir that he has handled himself well because
as he was saying his dad  Like
history repeating itself because his father already
lived through that stage, or at least he has
had that support that he knows how to deal
with it, fame has never gone out of his
mind and he has been able to see that in his father as
well
in him
[Music]
I was dizzy and unlucky
for everything for every event and tournament and
practice that I have to the attractions
because that was one of the wishes I
'm here and
show that you too and at the level of
the best player to let hide  that
maintains from behind as it is in new
york to vis what farmers in love
is nothing or pays for it
I continued to focus on the same mentality
that they wanted wine that I had a
saint
and focused what I came here on everything I
want
and  keep working
like outside and inside  the court and
always and all that
sometimes he
wants from Malaga
is once when they are typhoon
never
and this is his second
offer don't imagine we
really don't expect everything
that I have allowed to happen with
him is something extraordinary would be the
word
imagine  eight months ago in nine months they
were on holy sunday a place
called sunday where we are a
field called matrix a lo dynamic where
eight months ago he practiced with some
boys of a friend of mine called
carlos morales de battle who gave him a
lot of encouragement  opportunity and we did not have another
pending I feel
grateful only to God thanks to
that also because of the confidence in my
talent but I say based more on God the one
who gave was the one who opened his eyes
we are 100% sure that what
God  Manuel this
extraordinary has more for him than we
ourselves think but I have always said
that the valley from which there is age
all depends on his desire and he  he has
shown that his desire for life that
he has to overcome is that there is no
limitation he
understands my level in reality nba
and much more for he has already become a
great player daniel bayón or to be an
example ok and hans brother has been in the nba he
has lasted years  Despite what
people say, they took it a long time ago,
Diego, we do better than many people
[Music]